and welcome to Hannity and it is now
hello Vegas how are we doing all right
thank you so much
it's official we are only two weeks away
from the all-important midterm elections
that means two weeks from tonight you're
going to be hoping and praying and
waiting for those results to come in 10
weeks later
um anyway we're back out you know it's
true we're back on the road this time we
are in Henderson Nevada and coming up
Senator Tim Scott is here Senator Mike
Lee is here Larry Elder will join us Leo
2.0 Torell is here right great group of
people plus Republicans anybody here
support Republican Senate candidate Adam
laxalt and we'll be here he will join us
tonight the latest Insider Advantage
Paul has lack salt now up by two points
over his Democratic incumbent that
nobody even knows about even in the
state of Nevada Catherine Cortez masto
and we'll get to
I love a Hannity Town Hall crowd you're
great we'll get to this critical race in
only a minute we begin though with an
important update from Florida last night
Governor Ron DeSantis destroyed his
Democratic opponent on the debate stage
and it is now totally clear that
professional politician Charlie Chris
that doesn't know if he's a republican a
Democrat an independent he changes his
views and positions every day uh is way
out of his depth take a look listen I
know that Charlie's interested in
talking about 2024 and Joe Biden but I
just want to make things very very clear
the only worn out old donkey I'm looking
to put out the pasture is Charlie Chris
I'm proud of our history I don't want to
teach kids to hate our country I don't
want to teach kids to hate each other
and the way to stop discrimination on
the basis of race is to stop
discriminating on the basis of race
I sign legislation raising the penalties
for people who are trafficking Fentanyl
and Fentanyl analogs if you're
trafficking that garbage that poison you
are killing people in our state and we
are going to treat you like the murderer
that you are all right both Governor
DeSantis and Senator Marco Rubio they
are poised for a big election night but
nothing is certain if you want to
preserve freedom in the Free State of
Florida you've got to get to the polls
and by the way Thursday night we will
have a town hall in Florida with both
those men now meanwhile right here in
Nevada it appears that voters are poised
to reject the radical far-left policies
of incumbent Democrat Catherine Cortez
masto who's really liked by this crowd
as a senator she voted with socialist
Bernie Sanders a whopping 94 percent of
the time she is a card-carrying member
of the climate alarmist cult a big
proponent of the new green deal which is
socialism and get this last year under
Cortez masto's leadership Nevada's
Democratic party actually partnered with
the state Socialist Party for a quote
solidarity celebration now more recently
Senator Cortez masto was more than happy
to rubber stamp Biden's entire agenda
including the massive unfunded
government spending and of course
everybody happy you were going to hire
87 000 new IRS agents
[Music]
you'll be getting what I call the
Hannity treatment and she's also by the
way open to a ban on fracking she is
against energy exploration in Anwar and
even voted to stop construction on the
Keystone XL pipeline and if that had
been finished and completed by now we
would be importing 900 000 barrels of
Canadian Oil a day now the senator also
penned an op-ed begging the federal
government to reduce oil and gas leases
and with Biden she got her wish and now
gas is more than five dollars a gallon
right here in the state of Nevada and
that is over a dollar more than the
national average so you can thank your
Senator when you see her and her
Democratic colleagues when you go to the
polls by the way something else very
important for Nevada voters to consider
in 2021 she voted four separate times to
keep your schools closed and keep kids
out of the classroom at the very same
time she had no problem celebrating
herself at a lavish Gala in Washington
D.C all while kids in her state were
falling behind in math and reading and
writing because of her policies she's
also responsible for the crisis at our
Southern border as Senator she voted to
end title 42 which allowed the federal
government to quickly Deport illegal
immigrants during the pandemic she also
blocked Donald Trump's border wall and
in 2020 she suggested it was bigoted to
secure the southern border she even
voted to give stimulus checks to illegal
immigrants you all happy with that
but now in a truly miraculous election
conversion election year conversion well
Cortez masto is now pretending to be a
strong proponent of securing the Border
but we can see through her lies her
deception and this election year oops
change let me change my mind in fact so
can the Washington Post of all places
which has rewarded her many many
pinocchios along the campaign Trail so
let me ask all of you here anyone buying
uh your Senators current Senators lives
anybody you see are you supporting our
policies okay are you better off under
her leadership
is anyone happy a 41-year high of
inflation are you happy with that
are you happy with paying over five
bucks a gallon for gasoline anybody okay
so make no mistake There's No Better Way
Forward and that all happens two weeks
from tonight November 8th you get to
decide the power is in your hands hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else